French president Emmanuel Macon has
condemned a deadly shooting in Paris
which he says was a deliberate attack on
the Kurdish Community three people have
died in the shooting in the capital and
several others are seriously injured
police have arrested a 69 year old
French citizen in connection with the
attack
[Music]
paramedics rushed to take care of the
Wounded the Emergency Services launched
a large-scale operation in central Paris
after shots were fired in a Kurdish
Cultural Center a restaurant and a
barber shop
we don't love you we've gone we saw
people holding on to a man a big older
man
there were three people wounded in the
barbershop someone asked me to ring an
ambulance so I called them and the
police
the suspected shooter a 69 year old
French citizen was placed under arrest
the former train driver and hobby
Marksman is known to police he's been
charged with committing violence against
foreigners before after allegedly
injuring two migrants a year ago he was
released from jail earlier this month on
the judicial supervision
French interior Minister sharada Manan
visited the crime scene and said the
attacker had clearly wanted to Target
foreigners
will do everything we can to clarify the
details of the attack
and the motive
but it already seems clear that he acted
alone
dominant announced that authorities
would step up efforts to protect Kurdish
residents while he was visiting the
center clashes broke out between police
and demonstrators with protesters
throwing stones and police responding
with tear gas
TW correspondent Sonia falnikar and
Paris filled Us in on more details about
the shooting
well what we know Nicole is that the
shooting um took place
um this morning at 11 local time it
happened near the garden station in
central Paris this is a major uh train
station and the area around it is really
bustling and Lively with lots of
restaurants and bars and shops it's also
home to many members of France's Kurdish
community and witnesses there as we saw
in your report really describing chaotic
scenes uh people panicking fleeing the
scene when gunshots rang out now the
local mayor of the district has said the
three three places came under attack
here um that was the Kurdish Cultural
Center a hairdresser and a restaurant
and
um you know president macrod like you
said tweeting today about this heinous
attack targeting the Kurdish Community
the the the suspect himself who's been
arrested was apparently injured in this
shootout and and has been taken to
hospital what do we know about the
suspected shooter
he's a 69 year old French national
retired train driver he's known to the
police he's been previously charged with
racist violence he was in fact arrested
last December for attacking a migrant
camp in eastern Paris uh with the sword
um the French interior Minister Gerald
Armada as we saw in your report was
talking to journalists today at that
scene and he said that motive of the
attacker was was far from Clear
um uh he he said you know he was not
known to intelligence agencies there was
he was there was no file on him for
radicalization no known links as yet to
ultra far-right groups but he he is a
shooter in a sports club that's what he
said he has declared several weapons and
damana really made it a point to say
that at this stage you know he was far
from certain whether whether the shooter
had really targeted the Kurdish
Community or whether it was an attack on
foreigners in general
now members of the Kurdish Community
there in Paris were not only shocked
they were also frustrated because this
isn't the first time there be being
targeted in Paris is it
that's correct I mean this attack comes
you know nearly 10 years after three
Kurdish female activists were murdered
in Paris in January 2013 that included
the co-founder of the militant
nationalist Kurdistan Workers Party the
pkk and a Judicial investigation into
those murders is still ongoing in France
authorities here have spoken of the
involvement of certain members of
turkey's secret services so I think
there is a lot of anger here among the
Kurdish Community uh for you know at the
police for failing to protect them yet
again for failing to solve those murders
10 years ago so I think emotions really
running High among the Kurdish
population in France